[Music]
what are your superpowers again I'm rich
everybody you guys have been asking me
all about Justice League they showed off
all these new costumes they're getting
ready to film a bunch of new scenes so
there was an interview that one of the
producers did so I'm going to play that
then I'll talk about what's going on
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video and I'll name a new winner at the
end of the video so here's that
interview or anything that you could see
is about Justice League well I think
you've seen some things out there right
and we're excited about the film of
course you know we were sad saddened by
the events that caused act to have to
connect Snyder and Deborah Snyder to
have to leave and turn the reins over to
Joss Whedon but he was already working
with us on some of the scenes for the
additional photography that we're going
to be doing shortly and it was fortunate
that you know that convinced him and he
agreed to step in and finish the movie
help that finish his vision and we're
excited about that
so if you didn't know who that is that's
Charles Roven he's sort of like the
other big piece of the puzzle with geoff
johns in john berg at the top of Warner
Brothers DC movies Charles Roven has
been involved a lot longer than Geoff
Johns has Geoff Johns and John Berger
sort of the newer pieces of the puzzle
he acknowledges the circumstances around
Zack Snyder asking Joss Whedon to come
help out write some new scenes so I'll
ask that you please be respectful of
Zack Snyder and his family in the
comments obviously it's a very tragic
situation but what he explains is that
Joss Whedon came on a long time ago and
he was writing new additional
photography right now the movie is in
post-production typically what happens
with big Hollywood movies is they always
schedule time for reshoots because you
shoot your principal photography like
you write the movie you shoot the script
but then you get into editing and you
find that there are little moments that
are missing that help carry the story
forward like maybe there's a scene that
you need between two characters that
explains a later scene that you've
already shot so you come in later you
shoot like a little bit of extra stuff
then you throw it into the movie and
then you're done but if you're wondering
why Joss Whedon was the one that they
went to to do this it's probably because
it has
to do with a lot of the tone in the
heart of the movie because he's one of
the best ensemble directors out there
think about the Avengers in the shwarma
scene think about the scene where they
rally around Coulson after his death the
thing that catalyzes them it's such a
critical scene but it might not be one
that you come up with on your first pass
of the script when you're shooting you
say okay we need something to bring them
together so we're going to go shoot them
around this table in Nick Fury is going
to pull out this bloody card it's going
to inspire them to be the heroes that
Coulson thought that they were even
though Nick Fury was bluffing the whole
time so there's a little bit of humor in
that but mostly hard driving them
forward and it became this really
amazing scene so typically like when big
movies like this go into production they
already know what the big action set
pieces are you've seen a lot of them in
the Justice League trailer so far so you
have this big flashback scene where you
have the Amazons the Atlanteans combine
fighting the forces of apocalypse really
easy example of something that they knew
that they needed to explain so either
before they started writing the script
they're like okay we need to show a
scene with the history of Darkseid we
know we need to show a couple big
battles with the team and then we need
to show Superman coming back how does he
fit into that part of the movie
what are these interconnected scenes
where Batman goes around and tries to
recruit everyone the stuff that Joss
Whedon is working on is more of the
connective tissue so a really good
example of the connective tissue in the
group scenes the joss whedon are working
on or when they're all standing around
together between big action set-pieces
like what is that they're talking about
what things do they have in common what
are those moments of humor that they
find in each other so a lot of that's
already in the movie but obviously as
they started editing things Zack Snyder
found that there were a few things he
thought were missing he goes to Joss
Whedon and says we have five and
eventually six people we just need a
couple of moments with these characters
that display their heart catalyze them
and drive them forward into the next
scene so really what we're talking about
is probably less than like ten minutes
of screen time and what might end up
being like a two two and a half hour
movie so really is like Zack Snyder
throwing the touchdown pass all the way
down the field and then Joss Whedon sort
of stepping over the end zone which is
like a little bit of a bump to help out
but again these aren't big action
set-pieces they're not huge plot points
that's already been
done by Zack Snyder that was the stuff
that they were shooting earlier this
year it's really just like character
moments maybe punching up a bit of
dialogue but you also might have seen
that they put all of the costumes from
Justice League on display Warner
Brothers you get a much better look at
the Batman tactical suit at everyone
suits in the flash so you look at this
here it looks so much better than in the
footage that we've seen so far which is
behind the scenes footage it's not true
HD it has been mastered so obviously the
stuff that they show off at comic-con
isn't going to look nearly as good as
the stuff that you finally see when you
go into a movie theater that's something
that James Gunn was talking about he
showed off a lot of the ego the Living
Planet stuff at Comic Con
it looks ten times better when you get
to the actual movie when they finish all
the special effects especially the
Wonder Woman trailer if you look at the
early Wonder Woman trailers the colors
aren't quite as bright things don't pop
on screen quite as much but I did add
the opportunity to see Wonder Woman this
week I can't really post my review till
the embargo is up and that's like late
Monday night so my review will probably
just post early Tuesday morning a lot of
you been asking me about that yes it's
as good as everybody's been hearing I
think it's going to be a really high
watermark for the DC EU but I'll talk
about it in much greater detail when I
post that video the flash movie is also
moving along a lot faster now it looks
like they might end up getting Robert
Zemeckis I talked about this briefly
early on he was rumored to be in talks
then it kind of went away like he signed
up for another movie that was coming
before the flash movie was supposed to
drop
Matthew Vaughn of x-men and Kingsman
fame was rumored to be in talks for a
while he dropped out so Robert Zemeckis
came back in it's this big Hollywood
shuffle so you'll hear more about the
flash movie when we get to comic-con
they're probably just going to wait till
they actually lock down a director to
say hey this is what's happening this is
when the movie is probably going to come
out but just like the Batman tactical
suit you get a much better look at the
flash costume and they did explain to
all these wires just help keep it
together because of the way he moves so
you watch the flash TV show you know
that the costume that he wears on that
looks like leather but it's really just
like an advanced fireman suit that's
built to withstand the extreme
temperature and pressures of the speeds
that the flash moves at the Barry Allen
of the DC EU has been operating on his
own dumpster
being cobbling together his suit from
parts of fallen satellites things that
are designed to withstand entry into
Earth's orbit the most extreme of
situations the reason for the strings
are because there are so many different
plates and parts that are attached they
need to move around and they rattle they
would fly off of his body at the speeds
that he moves at so it's just extra
reinforcement and it makes it look extra
hardcore think abouts avatar suit it has
plates that move around it's made to be
frictionless but it's from the far far
future so it's way more advanced than
anything that the flash would be able to
find in today even in the DC EU the next
rail will drop we'll explain a little
bit more the story Philip had time to
finish way more the special effects
they'll have way more cool [ __ ] to show
off they haven't confirmed that it's
going to drop when the Wonder Woman
movie drops but that is the most logical
time so they'll definitely be showing
off new footage at Comic Con but I'm
expecting that to be a little bit
different and a little bit bigger but I
don't think they're going to wait that
long but because the Wonder Woman movie
is coming out next week and they haven't
said anything about a new Justice League
trailer recently they might wait just a
little bit more but just be on the
lookout for them attaching Justice
League footage to the Wonder Woman movie
theatrical release Marvel does the same
thing they attached a brand new
spider-man trailer to Pirates of the
Caribbean so we'll see how it goes down
whatever they post I will totally do a
video about it but leave all your
requests for DC EU videos I just posted
a flash TV show video I already have the
next couple of videos for that plan but
if you have any big questions about the
DC EU movies Batman and Nightwing
anything just let me know in the
comments congratulations to Nona Prince
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for brand new flash
and you can click here for Deadpool
bloopers Band material all the jokes
they had to pull out of the movie thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight